EILEEN NAUGHTON: --all
have a quick message for us
in the form of a video.
[LAUGHTER]
We're not going
to run the video?
OK.
We're going to
introduce the cast.
So I'd first like to welcome
the wise and wonderful Oprah
Winfrey.
[APPLAUSE]
Oprah.
Oprah--
[CHEERING] --you have some fans.
OPRAH WINFREY:
Wise and wonderful.
EILEEN NAUGHTON:
[CHEERING]
Oprah's humanity and sage
advice have touched us deeply.
And by us, I mean human kind.
Oprah is a media icon, an
Oscar-nominated actress,
producer, philanthropist.
She's also-- one of my
favorite things about you,
Oprah-- is you're the founder
of the Oprah Winfrey Leadership
Academy for Girls in
South Africa, which
provides educational
and leadership
opportunities for
academically gifted girls
from disadvantaged backgrounds.
Thank you for that.
OPRAH WINFREY: Big supporter
of Girls, Inc. too.
[CHEERS]
EILEEN NAUGHTON: Oprah
is a fairy godmother,
and she plays Mrs. Which
in "A Wrinkle in Time".
Welcome, Oprah.
And next, we have Ava,
Ava Duvernay, a filmmaker,
producer, and screenwriter who
directed "A Wrinkle in Time".
[CHEERING]
You can sit if you'd like.
And the 2014
[CHEERING]
Oscar-nominated
film, "Selma", which
chronicles Dr.
Martin Luther King's
Jr.'s leadership in the
struggle for voting rights.
Ava has the rare distinction
of being an Academy Award
and Golden Globe-nominated
director of both documentary
and feature films.
Welcome, Ava.
[CHEERING]
Next, we have Storm Reid.
Storm is here.
[CHEERING]
Storm began acting--
[APPLAUSE]
There's Storm.
Storm began acting when
she was three years old.
She's 14 right now,
so she's growing
up right before her eyes.
Storm plays the lead role of Meg
Murry in "A Wrinkle in Time".
And among other
roles, Storm appeared
in the Academy Award-winning
film, "Twelve Years a Slave".
And we have Gugu Mbatha-raw,
an English actress
known for many roles in
British TV and film, including
a recurring role in the
"Doctor Who" TV series,
and Plumette in
"Beauty and the Beast".
More than half the roles
that Gugu has appeared in
were directed by women, which
is, in itself, quite notable.
And in "Wrinkle in Time", she
plays Meg's mother, wonderful,
wonderful Meg's mother.
So why don't we sit
down, ladies, and start?
I was able to see "A
Wrinkle in Time" this week.
And it's a magical
visually enchanting movie
about a young girl who travels
across a time-space dimension
to save her father, a
physicist, from dark forces
in the universe.
Now what really struck
me, in the movie,
was how central women are
to the entire storyline.
Meg Murry is not a
damsel in distress.
She is a young woman on a
mission to find her father.
She was aided in her
quest by kind boys and men
and by mystical,
magical, powerful women.
So congratulations, ladies,
on a great achievement.
Ava--
[APPLAUSE]
--now I understand that you
weren't expecting and might
have been surprised to
receive a call from Disney
to direct this film.
And you hadn't read
Madeleine L'Engle's novel
before being offered
this project.
What was it about the
script and the project
that really appealed to you?
AVA DUVERNAY: Well, thank
you all for being here.
Really, really happy to see you.
And one thing I want to say
about the women in the book
and in our film is that
Gugu Mbatha-Raw does not
play just her mother.
She's an astrophysicist.
She's Dr. Kate Murry, which
is really important because we
want to make sure that we know
that girls can participate
in STEM.
That's important in medicine,
education, math, science,
all that good stuff.
So we want to make
sure we point that out.
Don't ask her to do any math
problems here on the stage,
but she does them in the movie.
But, yeah, it was really cool
to get a call from Disney.
Because sometimes in
Hollywood, Hollywood
likes you to ask
for permission, just
like a lot of people in life
want girls and women to ask
for permission to do things.
They want us to
sometimes pinch ourselves
and sometimes to prove that
you're worth doing something.
And so we find that in
a lot of places in life.
But now and then, you get
a beautiful experience
when people welcome you in,
and they love you just the way
you are.
And that's what happened
to me at Disney.
They called me, and they
said, we love your work,
we love your voice, and
we want you to just come
in and be who you are.
And those are the
kind of experiences
you want to embrace.
Those are the kind of people
you want to align yourself with,
and those are the
kind of people that we
were able to make "A Wrinkle
in Time" with at Disney.
EILEEN NAUGHTON: That's
a remarkable story.
You did not pick up a camera
to direct until you were 33.
AVA DUVERNAY: Now that's old.
Well, all of the
kids know that's old.
EILEEN NAUGHTON: It's
very young, actually.
AVA DUVERNAY: It's
older for directors
because most directors start
20, 21, in their early 20s.
So to start in your
30s, it's unusual.
EILEEN NAUGHTON:
So advice would you
give women, and
particularly young girls,
about following their
dreams, their tropisms
and having courage?
AVA DUVERNAY: It's
really just, what
you're doing now does not
have to be what you always do.
Who you are right now is not
who you're always going to be.
And just know that
there are steps to take.
There are other paths
to follow, to explore.
But don't feel
stuck in one place.
Embrace where you are now.
Learn what you can from it,
but also stay open to the fact
that there are other
things that you can do.
A lot of people talk
about me and my journey
in terms of race and gender, but
part of my story is also age.
Because in the industry that I'm
in, I got a start quite late.
And it's just proof that
nothing is impossible.
It really isn't.
EILEEN NAUGHTON:
Nothing is impossible,
ladies and gentlemen.
OK.
Oprah, the character
you play, Mrs. Which,
is the wisest woman
in the universe.
And as Eva said, in casting
you, she picked the wisest woman
in real life.
And--
[APPLAUSE]
--when you see the movie,
it's phantasmagorical,
and there are times where--
[CHEERING]
AVA DUVERNAY: You scared me.
OPRAH WINFREY: Sorry, y'all.
AVA DUVERNAY: I was
like, what's happening.
I'm sorry.
EILEEN NAUGHTON: We'll get
to you in a moment, Reese.
OPRAH WINFREY: Mrs.
Whatsit just popped in.
AVA DUVERNAY: It's Reese
Witherspoon, everybody.
[CHEERING]
EILEEN NAUGHTON: Hello,
Mrs. Whatsit just
came from the United
Nations, where
she was representing women
for International Women's Day.
So thank you, Reese,
for being here.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
Thank you, thank you.
I love seeing all
these Girls Inc. girls.
EILEEN NAUGHTON: We were just
in the middle of her talking
about the remarkable character,
Mrs. Which, that Oprah plays,
and this larger-than-life
figure who
guides Meg through the
universe and gives her courage.
Tell me what it is about this
role that appealed to you
because it seemed natural.
OPRAH WINFREY: I have to
say, well, first of all,
let me just say that one of
the reasons this role happened
to me is because I am a
friend of Ava DuVernay's.
I do not use that term lightly
because over the years,
I have chosen my
friends carefully.
And I have had a
best friend, Gayle,
who's been my best friend
since we were 21 and 22.
I actively sought
another friend.
[LAUGHTER]
Because Gayle is busy a lot.
And I actively sought
another friend.
So someone had shown
me a DVD of Ava's work
for another movie called
"The Middle of Nowhere".
And I liked the movie, and
then I went and looked up--
Googled her.
I Googled her.
Hello, Google, I Googled her.
[CHEERING]
And there I saw this
essence of someone
who I wanted to be my friend.
First of all, she was
a girl with glasses.
She looked like me,
and I thought, gee
I want to be her friend.
So I actively sought
to create an event
so that she could
come to my house
so that she would be my friend.
So that worked.
And then, I, as a
friend, when you
have a friend that you
love and you care about,
you want to do everything you
can to support your friends.
That's the kind of
friend you want.
You want a friend that
wants for you, as much
as you want something,
they want it even more.
So I wanted to support my
friend in doing this film.
So I said, I'm going to
come to New Zealand, girl.
And I'm going watch you
work and say, action.
And I just want to be there
when you tell all those people
action and cut.
And I kept saying it, oh, I'm
coming to New Zealand, girl.
I'm coming to New Zealand.
And she said, if you're
really going to do that, would
you consider reading this part.
And I said, yeah,
girl, I'll do that.
So that's actually
how it happened.
Because I was seeking
her as a friend,
I saw something in her
essence that has turned out
to be even more profound.
So then I read
this role, and it's
like everything I could
imagine for myself.
So I had a wonderful
mother, friend, teacher,
mentor named Maya Angelou.
Do you know who that is?
[APPLAUSE]
So I read her book when
I was about your age,
and then I ended up
becoming her daughter.
And so she was my spiritual
guide, mentor, teacher.
And I modeled this character,
Mrs. Which, from Maya Angelou
and from the Wizard of
Oz, Glinda the Good Witch.
So when Glinda the
Good Witch says,
you've always had
the power, I think
that's one of the
greatest teachings.
So to be able to have
Maya Angelou and Glinda
the Good Witch and then a
bit of my own self in there.
Because in the very
beginning, when
Mrs. Which first shows up at
the beginning of the film,
and she says to Meg,
all you have to do
is find the right frequency
and have faith in who you are,
that is my true philosophy
for how you live your life.
And if I had any advice to give
to you all today, that is it.
It starts at the
beginning of the movie.
All you have to do is
find the right frequency.
Because everybody has their own
frequency that is just yours.
And when you can
ride that frequency,
find the flow that is for
you and have faith in that,
unimaginable things
become possible for you.
So that's why I love the movie.
For that message and
for my friend, Ava.
EILEEN NAUGHTON:
Beautiful message.
And it's a beautiful lesson
for us here today, and I think,
Reese, welcome, you have found
your right frequency lately.
It's remarkable.
You all know Reese
Witherspoon, actress, director,
entrepreneur.
She has her own production
company, Hello Sunshine,
which really is your frequency.
REESE WITHERSPOON:
That is my frequency.
EILEEN NAUGHTON: But you've also
become really actively involved
in a number of women's
advocacy organizations,
so for that, we thank you.
I understand you read this book
when you were a young girl.
And how did you feel that
Ava's film enhances the story
and makes it more
relevant to the world
that we're living today
and experiencing today?
REESE WITHERSPOON:
Well, the book
was written quite a while ago.
I think Ava did an
extraordinary job.
I read this book when I
was 12, and I loved it.
And I think primarily because
I loved science fiction,
and I hadn't read
a lot of books that
had a girl at the center of it.
So I thought I was
Meg Murry and I
was going to travel through the
universe and do amazing things.
And I loved all of
that, and then I
read every book in the series.
So I was just
completely obsessed.
And so when Ava called me to
be in it, I was so excited.
I didn't know who
I would play either
because the misseses are all
billions and billions of years
old.
My son said, what does she
want you to play, an old lady?
But she, of course, had
this beautiful vision
of making them timeless and
celestial and intergalactic.
And they have these qualities
that are the qualities
that you'd want to have three
incredible women guide you
through the universe,
wisdom, a sense of fun,
and a sense of past.
And I just think
it was beautiful,
the way she imagined it.
EILEEN NAUGHTON:
And you have one
of the most beautiful
transformations
from a somewhat human form into
this mystical flying creature.
It was one of the most
exciting scenes in the movie.
Can we talk a little bit
about the special effects
and the challenge
in creating a movie
like that, that so heavily
relies on technology, really,
to produce these effects?
AVA DUVERNAY: Yeah,
no, I think it
was a beautiful team
that worked on the film
and the special effects with me.
Our visual effects
supervisor, Rich McBride,
also a great woman
over at Disney
who heads up special
effects there,
Mimi Steele, another
woman Tamara Kent.
So a lot of women on
our visual effects team.
But I think the actress
that was most impacted
by the visual effects was Storm
Reid because Storm Reid, as Meg
Murry, gets to fly.
And that's one of
the reasons why
I wanted to make this
movie, to see a girl fly,
hop planets, save the
world from the darkness,
and do all these amazing things.
But Storm actually, you
know, put her in a harness,
hiked her up in the air, and
she had to fly through the air.
It looked like it was fun.
STORM REID: It was fun.
EILEEN NAUGHTON: And
it was believable.
You did it believably.
STORM REID: Thank you.
I had some challenges, and
it was a learning curve
with the stunts and the special
effects and green screen
all working together.
It was a challenge, but Miss
Ava was right there in my corner
and helping me and showing me
previs, which is basically,
the animation of what's
going to be in the film.
So she helped a lot.
And it was still
hard because you
have to imagine the
unimaginable, which
is really hard.
But it came together.
AVA DUVERNAY: So
there was one scene--
STORM REID: No,
don't rat me out.
AVA DUVERNAY: I'm not.
I'm not.
She did a really good job, and
you'll see it in the movie.
But there was one scene
where I said, OK, Storm,
here in this place, you're
standing here in a field.
A tree is going to pop up
fully grown from the ground.
And she's like, OK.
And I said, so can
you imagine that?
But she's an actress so she
goes through her feelings.
So she's never experienced
a tree popping up
from the ground, fully grown.
So she was like, so it's
going to just pop up
like pop up from the ground
or on top of the ground.
I said, no, from the ground,
Storm, from the ground.
So it took an--
STORM REID: It took some time.
AVA DUVERNAY: --intellectual
approach to it.
But those are the kinds
of fantastic spaces
that she found herself in.
And she was 13 years
old when she did it.
So when you watch
the movie, imagine
this 13-year-old
actress, brilliant girl,
doing all of these
amazing things.
She's the real
warrior of our movie.
STORM REID: Thank you.
AVA DUVERNAY: Truly.
EILEEN NAUGHTON:
I love it, Storm.
[APPLAUSE]
Storm, Meg is a
beloved character
and a brave and determined
girl, a physics whiz.
You've mentioned that you really
saw yourself in that character.
What was it about Meg?
STORM REID: Yes.
Well, when I was reading
"A Wrinkle in Time"
in the sixth grade,
I didn't see myself
as being Meg because she
wasn't written that way.
And I'm a very visual
person so if I'm
reading something and something
is written a way, then
that's how it is.
And I could love it, and I did.
But once I got the script and
Miss Ava sent it over to me,
I felt like it just all clicked.
And it made sense,
and it made sense
for a girl at the
center of the universe
to be African-American
to represent
African-American girls
and just girls in general.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes, and just represent
girls in general.
And then, going into Meg,
I feel like everybody
can find a little piece
of Meg in themselves.
And I feel like Meg is very
determined and strong-willed,
and I feel like
I'm the same way.
So I feel like personally, we
kind of are on the same level.
And I feel like as girls and
as just teenagers growing up
in this dark world,
we're just trying
to grow up and find ourselves
and surround ourselves
by good people.
And sometimes, we have
challenges and mistakes
and faults on top of that.
So that's what we're
all going through.
EILEEN NAUGHTON: Well,
we're just human, Storm.
We love it.
OPRAH WINFREY: I think it's
important to note, too,
that Ava fought to get this Meg.
She fought to get Storm.
Will you tell that story?
AVA DUVERNAY: Oh.
[LAUGHTER]
EILEEN NAUGHTON: Oprah is
channeling her inner Oprah
right now.
AVA DUVERNAY: Well,
there were a lot of girls
all over the world who
auditioned to be Meg.
And you're looking for
that special girl who
encompasses everything that
this beautiful character has
symbolized for so many decades,
since the book was published
in 1963.
And so you're looking
for the one girl.
And so out of the hundreds
of girls that we saw,
Storm Reid was the one
who was meant to be Meg.
And I think it really speaks
to, everyone has their place.
Everyone has somewhere or some
place that they're meant to be,
someone in the world
that you're meant
to be connected with in
your family, something
that you're supposed
to be in your classroom
or in your life,
if you're an adult.
And once you align with
that place, it just clicks.
And that's what happened.
Storm was not just
in the right place
at the right time,
her whole life,
she was moving towards
being in that audition room
and being ready to be Meg.
All of the little steps that
brought her to be in the place,
in the time, in the
space to fulfill
and be something important to
someone else, and that was me.
And so whether you're an
actress and it's your time
to be in a movie,
which is a rare thing,
or whether it's your
opportunity to be someone
important to someone
in your life,
you have to cultivate
yourself each and every day.
So that when the
opportunity comes
to really stand up
and step up and be
someone important to someone,
that you're ready to do that.
And Storm did that.
So when it was her
time and I met her,
she was ready to be
someone important to me
and to be someone who
carries this whole movie.
So I think her journey
can speak to anyone,
in terms of prepare every day in
your life to be a great person
so that when the moment
of greatness arises,
you're ready for it.
EILEEN NAUGHTON: Beautiful.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, Gugu, you play Dr.
Kate Murry, Meg's mother
and a scientist and
an equal partner
to your wild scientist
physicist husband.
What did that feel like?
And rumor is that you
got to hang out at NASA.
Is that true?
GUGU MBATHA-RAW: Yeah.
Well, it was a
real honor for me.
I think getting to work with
Ava, who I've admired for such
a long time, getting to play
a scientist, as you said,
in the book, she's often
described as Mrs. Murry.
And the idea that we have
Dr. Kate, that she's not just
defined by her marriage, that
is an equal partner to Dr. Alex
Murry, played by Chris Pine.
And for me, it was really
fascinating to kind of cling
onto this idea that he's
been away for four years.
What this marriage
and this family
is based on is
obviously love, but also
this intellectual
meeting of minds,
that she's really found her
partner in life who is--
we sort of talked
about them like a sort
of power couple of science.
You know, that they
would do these TED Talks,
that they were
sort of like this--
I don't know, that their
connection was intellectual
and not just love and family.
And that's what
really kept her going
and kept her trying
to figure out
where he was in that long time.
So yes, we did get
to go and visit
JPL in Pasadena,
which was fascinating.
Getting to meet
real-- have you been?
So I saw heads go, yes.
Getting to meet real
scientists, people
who are really planning missions
to Mars, it was so interesting.
We also met this wonderful
doctor, Dr. Stephon Alexander,
who wrote this book called,
"The Jazz of Physics",
and he sort of
correlated the link
between the work
of John Coltrane
the saxophonist and
science and physics.
And I mean, it was
mind blowing to me,
and I can't pretend that I
have retained all of it now.
AVA DUVERNAY: We'll give
you a pop quiz on equations.
GUGU MBATHA-RAW:
But it was great.
And the fact that Ava had him
as the consultant on the movie,
to be able to introduce us
to that world of science,
is really inspiring.
EILEEN NAUGHTON: What
a rich experience
for you all and for us all.
You know, Time Magazine notes,
in its review of the movie,
that the book and
movie is about what
it means to be a source of light
in a world in which darkness
seems only to proliferate.
Oprah, you have a beautiful
line in the movie about darkness
being stronger than light.
Can you talk to us a
little bit about that
because several of
you have already
mentioned darkness in
the world, and this
is such an inspiring film.
OPRAH WINFREY: What
I think is incredible
is that when Madeleine
L'Engle wrote it in 1962,
she was talking about
the Cold War and all
of the experiences of
that day and Civil Rights
Movement and everything
that people were facing.
And what I know is
that you're never
going to run out of
darkness, as you're not
going to run out of light.
Because this is
the planet Earth,
and we are the planet of yin
and yang, of darkness and light,
of opposites.
And so the darkness,
which Mrs. Which says
is spreading so fast
these days, the only thing
faster than light
is the darkness.
And so you need
warriors of the light
to help banish the darkness.
If you think about it, if
we turned all the lights off
in this room, and you were
only holding a small candle,
that candle would
light up the darkness.
It would help to
banish the darkness.
It only takes a little
bit of your light
to banish the darkness.
It takes a lot of darkness
to overcome the light.
But just a little
flicker from you.
And so, wherever there is
confusion, wherever there's
jealousy, as Mrs. Which
talks about and is
able to show everyone in the
movie what that darkness looks
like, where it shows
up in your life,
just a little bit
of your light helps
to dissipate and destroy that.
So I think it's
about these times,
and all times are about
you reaching for the light
inside yourself.
And that's the real
work of your life,
is to figure out who
you are and how do
you become more of who you are.
Not what your
friends are, not even
what your mother and your father
and everybody wants you to be.
But this journey,
particularly at this stage
in your development,
is about, who am I,
and how do I become
more of that.
And how do I bring
more of my light.
First to yourself,
because you've got
to give it to yourself first.
You can't give to yourself
what you don't have.
So you fill yourself up.
And I used to be so
afraid of people saying,
oh, she's so full of herself,
she's so full of herself.
And now, I work on--
you've heard that before?
[LAUGHTER]
Forget those people.
Those people are
not your friends.
What you want to work on
is filling yourself up
with as much light, as much
kindness, as much goodness,
as much preparation.
Because that's
what luck is, being
prepared so when the moment
of opportunity shows up--
a lot of people
will look at Storm
and say, oh, she's so lucky.
She's lucky because
she was prepared.
Luck is just preparation meeting
that moment of opportunity.
If she wasn't prepared,
she wouldn't be here.
So your job is to fill
yourself with as much light.
Light comes from
all that is good,
all that is grace, all that
is kindness, and then offer
that to the world.
That will be your
gift to the world.
So that's why I love this movie.
That's the message.
EILEEN NAUGHTON: Well thank you.
And this movie gives us all--
[APPLAUSE]
--hope, and thank you all for
being warriors for the light
and for goodness.
And now, I think we have--
since we are live
streaming on YouTube,
we have a few questions
for all of you
from our global audience.
So we're going to go to them.
AVA DUVERNAY: Global audience?
EILEEN NAUGHTON: Yes,
it's a worldwide--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [SPEAKING SPANISH]
[END PLAYBACK]
AVA DUVERNAY: Yes.
Well, thank you.
Great question from Spain.
The soundtrack of the
movie is beautiful.
The first artist that
I put on the soundtrack
was Storm Reid's
favorite artist,
just because I wanted
to make her happy,
but also because
she's a great artist.
Her name is Kehlani.
I don't know if you
all know Kehlani,
but she's on the piece.
And then one of my
favorite artists,
because I want to
make myself happy too,
Sade is on the album.
So incredible.
Sia is on the album Chloe
and Halle are on the album.
Demi Lovato and DJ
Khaled are on the album.
So it's a really, really
great mix of voices.
And you put the music
with the images,
and it just uplifts you
as you watch the film.
EILEEN NAUGHTON:
Wonderful, beautiful.
We have a question,
next, from France.
OPRAH WINFREY: Bonjour.
EILEEN NAUGHTON: Brazil?
Oh, it's Brazil, not France.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
EILEEN NAUGHTON: Look
how beautiful she is.
OPRAH WINFREY: Yeah.
-
[END PLAYBACK]
EILEEN NAUGHTON: Aw, beijos.
AVA DUVERNAY: It's a
good one for you, Gugu.
GUGU MBATHA-RAW: Yeah, I mean,
for me, probably growing up,
I was relatively confident,
but I was an only child.
So I didn't have many people to
play with and stuff like that.
So for me, actually,
acting gave me confidence.
I think being able to find
something that I loved.
I loved dancing initially.
When I was about four or
five, I went to dance class,
and I just loved feeling free,
expressing myself with my body.
It sort of helped me get
rid of my inhibitions.
And it was so much fun.
I think that's so much
play to be had in acting.
So I think it's
finding what you love
and just sticking with that.
And I, obviously, was lucky
enough to make my hobby my job.
But, yeah, it gave me a lot of
confidence, acting and dancing.
EILEEN NAUGHTON: Beautiful.
Well, we could talk
for another hour,
but I'm afraid you all have
to get on flights to London
so you can open the
movie there tomorrow.
I want to thank all of
our guests for being here.
Disney's "A Wrinkle in Time"
is in theaters tomorrow,
March 9th.
Go see it.
OPRAH WINFREY: March
9th, March 9th.
EILEEN NAUGHTON: Before
we let you go, however--
OPRAH WINFREY:
The whole weekend.
EILEEN NAUGHTON: --because
it's so exciting,
we would like to invite all
of the girls from Girls Inc.
onto the stage to--
OPRAH WINFREY: What did you say?
EILEEN NAUGHTON: --take a
quick picture with the cast.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHATTER]
OPRAH WINFREY: All
right, everybody,
at the count of three, go yay.
1, 2, 3.
AUDIENCE: Yay!
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Everyone else,
please stay seated [INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE]
[NO AUDIO]